the Joe Rogan experience yeah there was
a guy last night of the Lakers game who
was throwing money just $1 bills into
the crowd and people were scrambling for
it and I was like this could be you
could be passing anything yeah easily
yeah I was like or this is a really
great way to see if you're counterfeit
yeah what'd he get people in trouble
yeah he'd [ __ ] losers and bucks for
free yeah
yeah there's a that's a weird thing
right the throwing money thing I'm so
rich I can throw money away when you're
like with no specified target right
right right you know if you're like I'm
so rich I'm gonna give it to a school
you know there'll be a nice thing I was
a rich I'm just gonna throw it in the
air yeah it's the ultimate in frivolous
spending yeah yeah I mean even at strip
clubs like I can get behind it cuz
you're like oh yeah you're paying this
lady but it's you're making her scratch
it all up together and yeah like she's
sweeping leaves yeah it's weird
I bet strippers really hate raking yeah
in the fall they're probably like oh
it's not even mine not even money but
they must get money thrown at them all
the time right oh they do they would get
it crumpled yeah and guys would throw it
that has to be the worst flattening it
back out yeah ironing yeah you're like
this isn't gonna get working the vending
machine
that's another job where there's no male
equivalent that's as humiliating because
like Chippendales dancers like if a
guy's a Chippendales dancer it doesn't
even come with a stigma now like he's a
good-looking guy with a six-pack and
wants to make some money yeah puts his
hog in a tube and starts dancing for
ladies with cowboy boots on it's normal
no one cares like hey our boyfriend used
to be a Chippendales dancer yeah pay my
way through college I mean it's a real
testament to how much better women's
bodies are like we're just like like the
male bodies like I mean I'm attracted to
it but like it's still just like it's
not something I want to see dancing
around necessary
it's a weird thing guys dancing is
feminine - yeah it's like a guy's just
sitting there dancing in front it's like
what are you doing it yeah like you know
when women are dancing they're letting
you know you could [ __ ] me yeah do you
know you could [ __ ] the guy guys will
[ __ ] anything it's so easy I say like
you want to [ __ ] a guy be the last one
there just be the one of those like it's
so we're just trying to different things
to like you know like yeah we like
attractive men but like you want to get
us like show us you're capable of things
yeah that's hot like your life is so
[ __ ] up to your Chippendales dancer
we're like yeah I'm just like what do
you uh how come you know your [ __ ] dude
you're 35 yeah like it's an accountant
or something you have a full beard you
should have a real job on a house like
stop it is such a different reaction to
like when girls go to see men strip or
men dancing they scream they're
screaming and yelling yeah guys are just
sitting there looking creepy guys are
sitting back like this they're like oh
you're flushed yeah it's a reverse of
roles for guys like the women are
aggressive because they want to make
money like would you like a dance dance
like the women to come up to you this is
crazy
they're coming up to me yeah it's like
yeah cuz you're pinging him
what do you think would change in
society if prostitution was legal um
I think you'd be a lot less guys that
are stressed I think there would be yeah
I mean I people would probably a little
nicer I think people would be nicer I
think those women would finally get like
like there'd be like they could have
like a union yeah you know like they
could not really hosel just break I want
to be at a prostitute union meeting I
really do I really
Jawa charging to their like I'm not
giving my fees the healthcare was not
good this you [ __ ] [ __ ] need to
step did you imagine what it'd be like
being in a prostitution meeting all
smoking [ __ ] job this job is [ __ ]
[ __ ] but there's also like one woman
in like a skirt and heels who's just
like we're not all like that
okay some of us where the we're the
classy ones like there's the classy
verse the unclassy side of the room you
know I think a girl who in college she
was uh she was a prostitute but she was
a prostitute
like she would [ __ ] guys she knew for
money mm-hmm and she didn't want to get
a job and she liked these guys they were
like older married guys and she [ __ ]
and she was trying to explain it and I
was like okay so you like you knew the
guys and you would [ __ ] them for money
she's an artist right and she was
explaining the whole thing I was like oh
okay well that comes up a lot where
there's there's some women who say that
like no I want to do this well if you
want look it imagine if you're a woman
right and you're in college and some guy
says I will pay you $2,000 to have sex
it'll take about an hour
mm-hmm versus you have to work for hours
and hours and hours and hours and hours
and the guy's a nice guy right and you
let you go okay he's like this nice
businessman and he maybe would have done
it anyway
yeah matin probably not but either way
it's not the worst thing in the world
you see you're not disgusted by he's not
treating you terrible right he just
likes sexual pleasure from a pretty girl
and you like money and then next you
know Jed's a millionaire like what is
wrong with that if that but that
obviously that's best-case scenario
right the worst-case scenario I think
it's pimps and people abusing women and
sexual trafficking and all the stuff
that's associated with the same sort of
thing that's associated with illegal
drugs is associated with illegal
prostitution crime organized crime I
mean that's that's what the real problem
is and look I have three daughters I
don't want anybody to be a prostitute
but if they were going to be a
prostitute I would like it to be like
legal thing not not my kids but if
you're gonna have prostitution if it was
legal first of all why isn't it legal
how come it's okay to [ __ ] anybody you
want but it's not okay to pay for it
that's crazy I mean it's it's it's the
oldest profession really so there should
be something at this point we should go
as a society hey we're not getting rid
of this yeah let's just figure out a way
to make it as safe touch people yeah
protect them from creeps make sure you
have security but maybe that's also part
of why guys some guys like it because it
is illegal or biddings dirty you know
him oh it's not
[Applause]